let's go to the phones and take our next
caller from the three-two-three area
code caller from 3 to 3 please introduce
yourself and jump right in here
hey David my name's Cameron and I'm
calling you from Los Angeles great
what's on your mind um I was interested
in knowing how you guys felt about
having more third parties involved in a
two-party system and range boding well
ranked voting I so I these two issues
I'm glad you're asking about them
together because they need to be thought
of together I don't believe that you are
going to see a significant pickup for
third party candidates until you have
ranked choice voting because the risk to
supporting a third party candidate is
that you actually end up helping the
candidate your most ideologically
opposed to so main has passed ranked
choice voting I believe there's one
other state Pat I don't remember which
that we reported which was Maine for
state elections not the federal not for
the federal election yeah it might have
been Nebraska again for state I might be
wrong about that so I I actually believe
that it would be great to have more
diversity of voices
I just think unless you completely upend
campaign finance to begin with and
really unless you in state rank choice
voting you're not going to see third
parties make large headway and for
people who don't know by ranked choice
voting what we mean is let's say that
the third party candidate is your
preferred candidate but by voting for
them let's imagine a real scenario you
want to vote for the Green Party if the
Green Party candidate is not going to
win you'd rather the Democrat than the
Republican but of course because you're
just voting once you vote for the Green
Party candidate that's a vote the
Democrat doesn't get that's now one vote
that potentially has helped the
Republican win with rank choice voting
you could rank what Green Party
candidate won and the Democrat too it's
after an initial summing summing up of
Round one votes the Green Party
candidate is not viable you go to
people's second choice votes and your
vote is shifted towards the Democrat and
I think Cameron you're thinking about
this issue in exactly the right way and
rank choice voting is just huge right
now as a political opportunity for third
parties
yeah I was making that too because I
actually started a third party in
California and my first piece that I'm
trying to pass is something that
involves more ranked choice voting in
the state all right very good well you
keep at it there and what's the name of
the party
oh we actually we long already yeah I
think that that that certainly might
have been something good question it's a
fair question yes unfortunately we did
not get to that one today